well you've heard the the old canard
probably haven't you about how a
movement if it sticks around too long it
will eventually become a business and
then it goes from a business into a
racket and I think that that has proven
correct over over history it is a it is
certainly true of the so-called
nevertrump movement now never Trump
meant something it served a purpose in
in the campaign especially in the
primaries the idea was very simple Trump
cannot be the nominee we cannot support
Trump as the nominee that was the idea
but as you may remember he did become
the nominee and and then he became
president so it makes no sense to still
identify as never Trump when Trump is
the president what does that even mean
now it's it's it's not a matter of
voting anymore he's already there so
never Trump never what never Trump what
never what is it that you're never doing
in regards to Trump the only thing that
makes sense now now that he's president
and this has been my this has been my
strategy for the last two years I think
it's the only honest path forward the
only rational path forward and that is
to to hold Trump accountable like we
should for any president any politician
to criticize him when he's wrong and to
support him when he's right and that
again is what we should do for any
politician any president and it is the
only morally and intellectually
defensible path any path aside from that
is is absurd now some former so-called
never Trump errs myself included
although I never really liked that label
but I would have been lumped in with
that with that category during the
primaries so this is what I've tried to
do I will defend Trump a hundred times
in a week if if I'll defend him
passionately
if I think that he's right or if I think
in a certain attack is unfair I've
defended him on many topics including
very stridently on the whole Cohen thing
you know
I think that the whole concept of taking
the president's lawyer and forcing him
to give up dirt on the president is
dangerous and unethical in the extreme
so of course I'm gonna defend Trump on
that but I will also criticized Trump
and I will criticize him passionately if
I think that he's wrong I'm not shy
about that I I don't care if it in as
far as I'm concerned anyone in the
audience anyone who reads me or watches
the show listens to it and has and
cannot stomach any criticism of Trump
whatsoever well then that's not someone
that I care to appeal to it if they
decide to never listen to me again I'm
perfectly fine with that honestly that's
someone who I don't think I even want to
appeal to that sort of person someone
who's just a narrow-minded sycophant who
is a just a groupie for a politician
that it's just not the kind of audience
that I personally want to assemble so
for instance Trump obsessively whining
about a man who died months ago and
attacking the man's family and
complaining that no one thanked him for
allowing the man to have a funeral that
I think is completely ridiculous and you
have to be a totally sold out sicko fan
to defend a trump on that score not
saying that I mean there are plenty of
reasons to be opposed to the kinds of
things that John McCain did when he was
politician and I was certainly a big
McCain Critic myself but this obsession
with him and attacking him after he died
this is just the kind of thing that it
of course if any Democrat president did
that to anyone it doesn't matter who
they are
every Republican would be freaking out
about it so it's just it's it's it is
indefensible now there are other never
Trump errs who have who have become sold
out who had become sold out sycophants
themselves they went from opposed
Trump and warning that we would be
disastrous for the country and for
conservatism and now they follow him
around like a puppy licking his palms
begging for treats some that former
never Trump errs have done that they
have completely flipped they went from
no we can't have Trump to now they are
bowing before him as a god and they
defend him on everything now those are
people that when they were never Trump
and now these are just people that that
are they're just pandering to whatever
they think the biggest audience will be
they have no integrity they have nothing
to offer there's no reason to listen to
them on anything on the other end though
you have some former never shoppers who
have become essentially Democrats and
they have decided to get revenge on
Trump by becoming full-time lackeys of
the left and I find these people
completely repugnant Bill Kristol
donated to Ralph Northam champagne in
Virginia because he's so Trump made his
tummy hurt and so then he went and
donated to Ralph Northam Ralph Northam
is the radically pro-abortion
infanticidal governor of Virginia who
also wore blackface now we didn't know
about the blackface thing we also didn't
necessarily know about the infanticide
thing when he ran we did know that he
was a Democrat and a pro-abortion
Democrat that's the only kind that
exists anymore
Christel supported him because he hates
Trump so much Cristal also helped to
start a publication called the bulwark
it is a it's a never never Trump a
liberal website because that's that's
basically what never Trump means of you
if you still identify as that that means
that that's what it's become it has
become a liberal racket it has become a
wing of the Democrat Party and that's
not because I'm not saying that if you
criticize Trump you're a Democrat no
that's the stupid thing to say
what I'm saying is if you still identify
as that what that means now is that you
will oppose Trump no matter what he does
and whatever he says you're gonna take
the opposite approach
so even when so that means if Trump
comes out and says oh we're gonna take
some money from Planned Parenthood or
we're gonna do this pro-life thing
you're all the sudden against it so that
just makes you a Democrat is what it
makes you they have this
Christel started this helped to start
this publication called the bulwark
which claims to be a website defending
conservatism which is a total joke and
it is a website which now pushes
Democratic liberalism it is in the
business of attacking conservatism and
and conservatives individually and
conservative values
they sent a pro-abortion extremists to
CPAC to mock pro-lifers just to give you
an idea of what the never Trump crowds
up to now they also had an article
reason I'm bringing this up they had an
article making the rounds yesterday
blasting a hole a whole host of
conservatives
for according to the article agitating
for civil war and the article gives
examples of various conservatives who
have been warning that a civil war is on
the horizon and the writer of the
article wags his little finger and at
these conservatives who are supposedly
engaging in violent and dangerous and
scary rhetoric about civil war except
that obviously the people who are saying
that we may be on the verge of a civil
war it's not that they want one they're
not saying that let's have a civil war
they're saying that I think that's where
we're headed now is that true well I
think it is it might not be fun to talk
now I think we are on that path but I
don't think there actually will be a
civil war and I'll explain why and this
is all it's not fun to talk about it is
unpleasant but that doesn't make it
wrong we have most of the ingredient
ingredients now for civil strife and
unrest if if not full-on civil war so
let's think about it here we have first
and foremost deep and unbridgeable
ideological divides what I say
unbridgeable I mean unbridgeable in the
sense that there is no meeting in the
there's no compromise okay it's not like
you've got one side saying one thing
another side saying another and you
could meet in the middle and you know
you each could have a little bit of you
know it's if you come to an
understanding or something like that it
the divides are so deep and irrevocable
that the only way to meet is for one
side or the other to give up their
defenses and to surrender and say you
know what you're right that's that's the
only thing that can happen so you have
one side saying for instance that babies
aren't people and advocating for the
continued slaughter of the unborn they
say that it's that that biological sex
isn't real
they say that America is systematically
racist and sexist masculinity is toxic
religion is poison let's let's have drag
queens come in and talk to
kindergarteners that kind of thing then
you have the other side that takes the
opposite position on all of those topics
these are positions that cannot be
brought together in understanding like
either unborn babies our people or they
aren't either it is a horrendous crime
against humanity to kill those
individuals or it's perfectly fine you
know it can't be sort of one and sort of
the other so we have that we also had as
a corollary to the ideological divide we
also have a cultural divide and this was
one of the primary things that led to
the SIB the first let's hope the only
civil war in 1861 even aside from
slavery or politics or economics all of
those things obviously played a part in
in in the civil war but the fact also
was that the antebellum south and the
industrial north were like two different
countries with people in both countries
who didn't understand or particularly
like the folks in the other on the other
side now our cultural divide isn't so
much between industrialized and
agricultural or whatever but it's it our
divide is more religious
and ideological and kind of
philosophical in nature which i think is
shall we say an even spicier issue to be
divided on because at the end of the day
even in civil war times you had people
with very different from very different
cultures different priorities and things
but they did agree on some really
fundamental basic issues first and
foremost being they were all religious
they were almost all Christian they
believed in God I mean almost all of
them did and so that is a obviously a
one really significant foundational
similarity that we don't even have that
anymore we also have economic divides we
have Geographic divides now the
geographic divides aren't quite as
clear-cut as North versus South but you
could point on a map - well these are
basically liberal areas and here are
conservative areas the point is yes if
civil war is a chilly let's say then
we've got most of the ingredients we've
got the beef we've got the pork yes you
should put a little pork in your chili
we've got the spices we've got the
peppers no beans ever in chili but we
are missing one ingredient we're missing
the beer in the chili and you can't make
a chili without a beer and the beer for
us in this particular chili is is really
simple it's its willingness we have we
don't that that's the difference is we
don't we don't have sort of the
willingness to fight like they did back
then so the men in the Civil War area
era these were these guys were fighters
especially in the south they were
willing to fight it out they also were
not living comfortable lives many of
them a lot of the generals were living
comfortable lives but the the grunts the
the infantry guys they were coming from
poverty they were coming from dirt
floors and working in the fields that's
the life that they have
the thing that saves us from violent
conflict I think is that we're pretty
comfortable at the end of the day we're
pretty lazy
we're unwilling to to completely upend
our apple cart
and make the sacrifices that such a
conflict would require and I say that
with gratitude I mean I don't like that
people are lazy but I'm grateful that
we're not gonna have a civil war I don't
that's I don't want that 600,000 people
died in the Civil War anyone who would
root for that is a psychopath but my
point is simply that people aren't you
know the the the the factor that I think
prevents civil war in our case is that
people aren't willing to do it back in
the Civil War times guys were still
dueling right you had duels like if a
guy insulted you you would say sir I
challenge you to a duel and you would go
out you would shoot bullets at each
other's head these were guys willing to
die to defend their honor now these days
if somebody insults you and you pull out
a gun and say sir I challenge you to a
duel the guy's gonna say oh what dude
dude okay I'm sorry never mind forget
what I just said it's the calm down man
like take it easy and that would be the
end of it and that's probably good it's
better to end that way than by shooting
someone in the head but but those were
different sorts of men and they were men
who weren't afraid of death really not
not near well they were afraid but not
nearly as afraid as we are they had much
more physical courage typically and I'm
not advocating that we prove our courage
by dueling or by fighting civil wars I'm
just observing a fact so that was the
beer and their chili that was the one a
remaining factor that they had they got
it we have a lot of the things that they
have but they also had they had that
kind of desperation that willingness
that for lack of a better term that more
violent kind of nature that we don't
have and that's what's gonna stop it but
it prevents a civil war I think it will
not prevent the continuing and deepening
divide between us that's the thing
and where does that divide lead I don't
know exactly I'm not a amount of profit
I can't prophesy about it but it doesn't
lead anywhere good and I could more
realistically see a scenario where I
could see a scenario where you've got I
mean think look at the the riots and
things we had especially for a period of
you know a year or two there where it
seemed like every few weeks or every
couple of months there would be a riot
and one of these cities I could see a
scenario where you see where things like
that happen much more frequently how do
we stop how do we pull ourselves back
from that I wish I had the answer to
that question I don't know because as I
said there is no easy middle ground that
we can find all right uh let's see here
Joe Biden a little bit of political news
Joe Biden is about to announce his
presidential campaign Biden by the way
is 76 years old soon to be 77 so I want
you to think about something here you
have to be 35 years old
to run for president now nobody seems to
complain about that right nobody calls
that ageism there are certain realities
about age and one of those realities is
that typically wisdom and it when you
age you gain wisdom and you gain
experience and so we would say that if
somebody is 25 or 26 years old they
aren't they are going to probably be
short on wisdom and experience and so
that's someone who we don't want in the
White House not because not because
we're discriminating against the hammer
because there's anything wrong with
being 25 or 26 years old there's nothing
wrong with being any age it's just you
can't help it is it you're you're
inevitably going to be every age until
eventually you die and then you're not
going to be anymore ages after that so
we don't we don't
consider that ageism well there are
realities about age on the other end of
the spectrum - and the most harsh
reality on the other end of the spectrum
is that age will eventually kill you
unless something else does the job first
age is a deadly thing and before you die
if you live long enough your mental and
physical capacities will diminish it's
going to happen the only way that it
won't happen to you is if you die before
that but if you don't then it will
happen it happens to everyone we are
mortal animals this is part of the
package and so that is why it's
completely absurd for elderly men in
this when you're 78 years old Joe Biden
is going to be 78 years old on
Inauguration Day that is elderly the the
life expectancy for men in America is 76
now yeah that number is way down by men
who died much younger but still point is
it's it's really old way too old to take
on the most stressful job on the planet
now as I pointed out before think about
what the job did to George Bush who was
a young man when he got into office or
Barack Obama also read both of them
relatively young men think about what
they look like after eight years it aged
them considerably now think about what
it would do to a guy who's 78 when he
gets into office by the time midterms
roll around Joe Biden will be 80 years
old at 80 years old you will be you will
have been AARP eligible for 30 years at
80 80 years old is also the age where
people typically start to get dementia
if they're gonna get it it's not ageism
cam not being a that's just a reality at
80 years old your chances of getting
dementia developing to vent dementia are
pretty good at it at the age of 50 or 60
they are very very low what
when a president gets dementia does
anyone know what do we do about that I
mean how do we know that he I mean you
sometimes it's not all the obvious right
away and what happens when he has the
early onset of dementia do we what do
you do well we've never really had to
figure that out but Joe Biden's
insatiable thirst for power may force us
to to figure it out Joe Biden and Bernie
Sanders have been running for political
office or holding political office for a
hundred years between them they just
can't get enough of it and they're gonna
keep going until it literally kills them
and I think that's reason enough to to
to oppose their candidacies and I
haven't even gotten into their bad
policy ideas but before you even get to
that the fact is these are elderly men
who are obsessed with power and cannot
let it go anyone who wants to be
presidents so bad that they'll run for
president at the age of 78 that is
someone who should not be president you
know the other problem I think with
having someone at that age be president
is that an elderly person isn't going to
be around to reap the consequences of
their policies and their actions and I
think that's just not fair to the rest
of us like it's not fair that you have
control over the future of America and
it's a future you're not even gonna be a
part of that's not fair to I so we
deserve to have somebody in there who's
gonna have to also live with the
consequences of whatever they do how do
you hold such a person accountable I
mean when someone is eight years old and
their president
they are almost definitely going to be
dead within 10 years probably be within
5 now that I look it's it's not a
pleasant reality it's just the reality
of the situation most people don't live
past 85 especially men yeah there are
exceptions but most people don't so it's
just why should a person like that care
what the voters think well they're not
going to they have nothing to lose and
you know it's it's it's it's
it it's difficult enough when you have a
lame-duck president like when you've got
a some a president on his second term
and he knows he's leaving after this
well what about when you have someone
who's about to be term limited out of
existence itself I mean how do you how
do you control someone like that now
there are many reasons to not vote for
Bernie Sanders and Joe Biden I just
think that this is this is definitely
one of them and this is why there should
be an age limit on the presidency it
should be
you can't run until you're 35 and you
can't run after you're 75 that gives you
a good 40 year window to become
president and guess what if you if you
can't do it in those 40 years then it's
just over I let it go go home and play
with your grandchildren you don't get to
be president well you know what almost
nobody gets to be President so that's
okay it's not much of an injustice
I'm never gonna be President you've
never been president never will be so so
so why should Joe Biden be President Joe
Biden ran for president the first time
thirty years ago okay I mean you let it
go now it's it's over every time I talk
about this there are people who say I
was talking about it yesterday and
someone said well my my grandmother is
92 years old and she sharp as a tack and
your your generalizations are ageist oh
come on
first of all nothing I have said here is
factually inaccurate are you gonna deny
that that your mental and physical
capacity is diminished generally over
time are you going to deny that you're
much more likely to get dementia at 80
than you are at 50 are you gonna deny
that most people die before they're 85
no you cannot deny any those are just
facts to call something a gist because
it's a it's like if I said you know one
year olds can't can you need me diapers
because they can't you can't use the
toilet you said well that's ages how
could you make such a sweeping statement
about one year old it's not ages that's
just a reality of their age yes you're
92 year old grandmother may be sharp as
a tack but there are most 92 year old
most people don't live to 92 most people
die before that
and and most 92 year olds who are living
they may be sharp 492 but they're not as
sharp as they were when they were 50 and
they so physically they're definitely
not going to be as as there is no 92
year old living today who is in good
physical shape compared to a 50 or 40
year old it's just this we are mortals
okay it's just what happens I know it's
uncomfortable to think about you know I
think part of this when I talk about
this and people are react how dare you
say that I you know what I think part of
it because the reaction on the surface
seems so ridiculous because everything
I'm saying is factually correct you
cannot deny it
but the people who react that way I
think part of it is just a fear of death
like they're afraid of their own
mortality they don't want to admit that
this is just what happens like we are
all marching into this we're all
marching into the abyss of you know of
death and diminishment and that's where
we're headed it's just I'm sorry I don't
I don't like it any more than you do
there is no good reason there is no good
reason to have seventy eight year olds
running for president there isn't it
does not benefit the country you cannot
think of a good reason for it
it would not harm the country in any way
whatsoever to cap it at 75 and I could
think of many ways that would help us I
mean at 75 you forget about running for
president you should have to go and
retake drivers doesn't mean the fact
that we let people drive until they're
90 without with it that alone is crazy
enough let alone be President so all
right let's see I think I'm gonna jump
ahead to emails because there were
several emails emails that I wanted to
answer some really interesting subjects
okay let's check
in with the Inbox Matt Walsh Oh at
gmail.com
Matt well show at gmail.com if you want
to get a hold of show this is from
Daniel says dear man I am a firm
believer in Jesus Christ and thoroughly
enjoy the subject of apologetics one of
the tougher subjects that I have often
wrestled with is the veracity of
Scripture while the Bible states that
the Word of God is forever preserved in
heaven it does not explicitly state that
God preserves his word here on earth a
great example of this is found in 2nd
Kings 22 where King Josiah finds the
book of the law hidden within the temple
this means that there was a long time
where the people of God did not have
portions of Scripture how do we defend
the Canon that we have today I've often
heard the Bible challenged in that it is
simply a conglomeration of text chosen
by men historically this is true and the
accusation is hard to deny ultimately I
personally accept the veracity of
Scripture by faith since it is so
accurately describes the world around me
and how I relate to God that being said
that is a defense from faith and while
there is nothing
unholy about it it is a difficult
defence with which to convince a skeptic
along this topic I have a couple of
other related questions being a
Protestant I have a general
understanding that Catholic faith
accepts the Apocrypha I am not sure
where you stand on this and please
correct me if I'm wrong but could you
let me know why or why not you accept
the Apocrypha of Scripture last of all
within Protestant circles there's often
a very strong debate concerning
translations while I do not believe that
any translation is god-breathed
there are many around me who do namely
the King James Version
I believe that translations can be open
to error and the only truly script the
only truly scripture and the only I
think means to say the only Scripture
truly inspired by God
are the original manuscripts which
appear to have been lost to time I do
believe that a translation can be truly
evil when it distorts and changes
biblical doctrine but I believe there
are many consistent and faithful
translations that I would deem
acceptable for knowing God how would you
define the need for looking at
translations as well as addressing those
who choose one translation only and
condemn the rest all right
thanks to that email it's a great email
very meaty and this is why that's why
this is my favorite part of the show
because I get these great topics and I
don't even consider them questions like
it's not like you're coming to me for so
I could teach you because I think a lot
of you probably know more than I do
about almost everything but it's just
you're bringing up a topic that we could
talk about which I really appreciate and
I also like how Daniel you same thing I
said there's someone yesterday I think I
think it's great how you're thinking
about these things and being being
critically minded I love when I see that
in Christians I think that unfortunately
it's somewhat rare it I could be wrong
my general impression my feeling is that
most Christians at least in America
don't really think about these things
they don't think about the Bible
they don't really try to understand it
especially not from in a store a
historical standpoint and I think that's
unfortunate
and what so then one of the problems is
probably running in this Daniel is that
if you are someone who thinks about this
and reads about it and wrestles with it
struggles with it you can get to feel
kind of lonely because when you try to
talk to someone else about it another
Christian you just get this blank stare
like they didn't even that's and they've
never even thought about it
and so if this could be a forum for
these kinds of conversations so we know
that we're not alone then I think that
that's a good that's enough all right so
we do believe the Bible is the inspired
Word of God obviously however that idea
of the inspired Word of God doesn't have
one obvious meaning so it's easy to say
oh it's the inspired Word of God
okay yes what does that mean though what
does it actually mean and don't just
spit talking points out may your
doctrine what does it actually mean
though there's a debate to be had and a
debate has been had for centuries about
what that means exactly and how that
works
very simplistic sort of childish
understanding is that God basically bent
down from heaven and he said hey come
over here and he audibly spoke the words
of that would eventually be in the in
the Bible he spoke those words to the
writers of these various books and those
writers just became essentially cosmic
stenographers and they just wrote down
what God was telling him they said well
was that you that you said their God
about okay I'm going to write that down
and that is not how it worked as we grow
and we study and we mature we begin to
see that that's just not the way the
Bible came together the Bible is a
collection of different types of
literature across many centuries written
in many different regions and written
for many different reasons to many
different sorts of audiences and written
by people who did not know that they
were writing something that would
eventually be compiled in a book that we
now call the Bible that's the reality
and we also know this is the important
part we know that many of these writers
used sources or probably they all did
that used sources they conducted
investigations they went through a
process that would have looked like a
very human process and they incorporated
oral tradition and they incorporated all
these different things Luke you know
Luke even tells us at the beginning of
his gospel that he conducted interviews
and he did research and so on Luke does
not say that Oh an angel came down from
heaven and told me all this and I wrote
it down he doesn't say that he says he
went in and he tried to investigate and
figure out what that's going on and this
is what he came up with he tells us that
so what does it mean to say that the
Bible is inspired it means that God
somehow guided that human process and
that everything in the Bible is in the
Bible because God wants it to be I think
it's sort of as simple as that I think
that's the best way of looking at it
everything's in
because God wants it there I think it's
better to say that than to say something
like everything in the Bible is accurate
I'm not saying that everything in the
Bible is not accurate but I am saying
that there are many different forms and
genres of literature in the Bible and
for some of those genres to call them
accurate just makes no sense what does
it mean to say the Song of Solomon is
accurate what does it mean to say that
the Psalms are accurate what does it
even mean to say that you know the book
of James is accurate you know when
you've got poetry or you know
essentially sermons which is which is
what the the epistles do letters to call
them accurate it just it's true in a
certain sense but it's not exactly the
words you would use like you're not
going to listen to you know emotes our
sympathy is a simple sympathy Simmons
peak
Symphony now you listen to Mozart and
say well that that's a very accurate
like that doesn't mean anything what
you're gonna say is that it's beautiful
it's deep it's meaningful you can use a
lot of great words to describe it not
necessarily accurate so III think that
the the best way of putting it is as I
said it's there because that's God
wanted it to be there because we will
get something from it that we need to
get from it and what that thing is will
be different depending on what book were
reading so how do we defend that notion
well I agree that you can't defend it by
demanding that the person you're talking
to believe the Bible on faith
you can't defend the Bible by using the
Bible this is something that Christians
try to do and it's kind of embarrassing
because it's it's they're essentially
trying to prove the veracity of the
Bible by pointing out that the Bible
claims that it has veracity which first
of all is is circular reasoning to say
well why should I believe the Bible
because
says it's true yeah but why should I
believe that well because the Bible is
true you see it's a circle and that's
just that's not good reasoning you're
not gonna be able to convince anyone
that way and the second problem is that
the Bible actually makes no claims about
itself because no as I said no one who
contributed to the Bible knew that they
were contributing to something that we
now call the Bible none of them knew
that so I think we have to be able to
launch a more sophisticated defense
which is a whole other subject I can
talk about for 10 hours but I think that
defense has to be historical
philosophical theological literary
spiritual all of it we have to be able
to launch a defense that is multifaceted
and that engages on all of these
different levels and what what we
certainly know is not the case is we
can't convince someone that the Bible is
true by just throwing it at them and
beating them over the head with it and
say the Bible says that the Bible says
it and that's a stereotype it's a cliche
but that is what some Christians do and
it is so incredibly ineffective and
they're making fools of themselves you
asked about what you call the Apocrypha
that would be a collection of books in
the Old Testament Tobit Judith wisdom
Maccabees a couple others I don't
remember all the the Protestant Bible
excludes those books and you know you
call it Apocrypha obviously I don't call
it Apocrypha it's sort of a negative
label to use obviously so why do I
accept it well it's simply a matter of
history for me when I look at the
Septuagint the the Greek Trent the
earliest Greek translation of the Hebrew
Bible I see that most of those books are
in it and that is very convincing to me
when I read the Church Fathers I see
that most of them accepted these books
that's very convincing to me I think
that a Bible with those books has a
better historical claim than a Bible
without them and it's really as simple
as that and by the way the Catholic
Church is not the only one that accepts
them
except some the Coptic Church except
something cut the church has been around
since the very beginning the Catholic
Church the Coptic Church can trace its
roots back almost 2,000 years the Greek
Orthodox Church accepts them the Russian
Orthodox Church accepts them a lot of
very ancient churches accept these books
and that should tell us something if
somebody decided in the 16th century
that these books shouldn't be in there
well personally I'm more inclined to
listen to someone in the 3rd century or
the 4th century someone who was a little
bit closer to not only when these books
were written but when they were
ultimately compiled and everything
finally on translations as I've said
before the claim that the King James
Bible the King James Version is the most
accurate the only inspired translation
is completely absurd the whole house of
cards comes tumbling down as I talked
about a few weeks ago just based on the
fact that the King James Version has the
Johanna and kama which is an
interpolation and the Epistle of John
which talks about the Trinity and that
we know was not in the earliest
manuscripts and was added in centuries
later by someone who decided oh you know
what this should really be in there and
I'm just going to put it in so that it
shouldn't be in there the King James
Version has it almost no other Bible
translation you're gonna find in America
has that because most almost every
scholar knows it shouldn't be there so
that's a pretty glaring error that the
KJV has doesn't make it worthless I
still I still read the KJV I like that
style especially for certain books but
to call it the most accurate or the only
inspired version is just completely
wrong I'm not dogmatic about
translations I have a bunch of
translations back there I flip between
them as you said they you know some some
of them have issues they have different
sorts of issues and so you know you
can't get too attached to one
translation that's my feeling by the way
if you don't read Greek and you don't
read Hebrew then all your only stuck
with pay limitations talk to someone who
reads Greek and they'll tell you that
what you're getting in the English Bible
it is it's the best you can do
it's better
nothing but it is you're missing a lot
when you don't know the original
language and I don't know it so I
already know so it's just it's it's
already weird to be really attached to
an English translation if you're gonna
get really attached to a translation
they get attached to a Greek trick learn
Greek and get attached to that alright
um okay that was a long answer there was
one other here this is also a long one
that's alright I'll do it from Robert
says hi Matt I enjoyed your thoughts on
Pascal's wager I agree that it's the
weakest Christian argument I think the
best Christian argument at least one of
the best is one from CS lewis saying
that jesus must have either been Lord
lunatic or liar because only someone
who's a conman crazier actually God
would claim to be God as Jesus did I've
always thought that this is a really
logical argument and I'm not sure how
unbelievers deal with it or dismiss it
seems rock-solid to me have you heard
this argument what do you think yeah
Robert that's the trilemma argument I've
actually dealt with it on the show I I'm
pretty sure I love CS Louis I get what
he's doing in the argument but no I'm
afraid that it's I don't think it's a
good argument I think it's maybe even
weaker than Pascal's wager and I think
it's so by far the weakest argument that
CS Lewis ever made which is which is a
shame that it became his most famous
argument he made a lot of great
arguments and I think that maybe is his
worst one yet that's the one that a lot
of people have grown attached to so
let's let's read what CS Lewis did he's
not the first one to make this argument
by the way but he did popularize it this
is from mere christianity CS lewis says
i'm trying here to prevent anyone saying
the really foolish thing that people
often say about him I'm ready to accept
Jesus as a great moral teacher but I
don't accept his claim to be God that is
the one thing we must not say a man who
was merely a man and said the sorts of
things Jesus said would not be a great
moral teacher he would either be a
lunatic on the level with a man who says
he is a poached egg or else he would be
the devil of hell you must make your
choice either this man was and he is the
son of God or else a madman or some
the nurse you can shut him up for a fool
you can spit at him and call him a demon
or you can follow his feet and call him
Lord and God but let us not come with
any patronizing nonsense about his being
a great human teacher he has not left
that open to us he did not intend to now
it seems to me obvious that he that he
that he was neither a lunatic nor a
fiend and consequently however strange
or terrifying or unlikely it may seem I
have to accept the view that he was and
his God very eloquently put but there
are two problems first the argument
operates from the assumption that Jesus
actually did say everything that the
Gospels claim he said and that's a fine
assumption among us Christians it's one
that I share but the argument isn't for
Christians right if you're going to
you're not gonna make this argument to
another Christian they already agree so
if you're making this argument then you
must be making it to someone who is
outside the faith to non-christians and
non-christians do not assume that the
Gospels are 100% accurate if they did
they'd already be Christian so you know
you're talking to someone who looks at
the Gospels and says you know that's a
book like every other holy book it's
it's a you know there's maybe some
accuracy in it there's some fables
there's some this and that that's how
they're looking at the Bible so when you
say hey Jesus claim to be God which
means that he must have been God or else
he was crazy or a conman the obvious
response from an unbeliever is okay well
then he didn't claim to be God and this
would be a perfectly logical retort from
the perspective of an unbeliever
especially because almost all of Jesus's
most explicit claims to divinity are in
the Gospel of John which was written
written last and written maybe 60 or 70
years after Jesus died so Aperol a
person needs to say to diffuse this
argument from CS lewis all a person
needs to say is well the Gospel of John
was it was written 70 years later by
someone who obviously was not an
eyewitness from their perspective and it
is a theological and poetic
work and also a mythological work and so
I just don't I don't accept that it's
historically accurate and like I said
that's a that is a logically sound
response the second problem with the
argument though we don't need a second
argument because the first problem is
enough is devastating enough but the
second argument is that it's not
necessarily true that anyone who claims
to be God and isn't God must be lying or
crazy I mean even today you could talk
to people who are kind of these new agey
pantheists and they'll say that yeah I'm
God we're all God you know God is
everything and everyone we're all God
now that's nonsense it doesn't mean
anything but that's what they would say
Jesus was not a pantheist obviously but
the point simply is that you could
conceivably come up with a spiritual you
could come up with a scenario where a
person may develop a spiritual notion of
their own divinity without necessarily
being totally insane and while actually
believing what they say it is it is so I
just I think that it's it's too
simplistic on those grounds as well I
think it is it's conceivable that a
person could come to think of themselves
as some sort of divinity without being
crazy especially in ancient times I mean
the Roman emperors considered themselves
divine they weren't crazy and I don't
think they were lying exactly they
really thought it was true of course it
wasn't so you know those are the two
problems with it I would recommend
everyone I go go read CS Lewis so many
great arguments so many great points
that he raises that's just not that's
just not one of them and I'm telling you
I mean take this argument and present it
to any atheist and what I just said
that's exactly what they're gonna say
and then so then what they are
it really becomes is is an argument
about proving the historical veracity of
the Gospels because that's what it all
hinges on so I would say now if we cut
out the trilemma thing and just talk
about that and if you feel like you can
prove that or provide evidence for that
then great just do that because if you
can get them to accept the historical
veracity of the gospel then you don't
even need the trilemma because they're
already gonna be Christian at that point
right all right we'll leave it there
thanks for the great questions and have
a great weekend
Godspeed today on the Ben Shapiro show a
Time magazine journalist reveals the
true motivation behind a o'seas rise and
we checked the mailbag that's today on
the Ben Shapiro show